on va d'abord s'intéresser donc au
grenelle des violences conjugales et
vous pose une question ce soir sur
twitter ce que vous pensez que les
premières mesures annoncées sont
efficaces elles l'ont été en tous les
cas par le premier ministre qui a ouvert
cette conférence était cet après midi on
les écoute
nous allons donc mobiliser 5 millions
d'euros supplémentaires pour créer 1000
nouvelles places d'hébergement et de
logement d'urgence de 150 seront créés
en 2020 dans les centres d'hébergement
d'urgence pour assurer des mises en
sécurité immédiate et le ministre du
logement créera par ailleurs 750 places
grâce à la mobilisation de la location
de logements temporaires ce logement
sera adaptée aux femmes qui partent avec
leurs enfants
il ne s'agira pas d'un hébergement
d'urgence dans une structure collective
elles pourront y rester entre six mois
et un an
bihorel cluzel un premier commentaire
sur ces mesures et et bien tout d'abord
je suis frappé de façon générale par la
place que prend ce grenelle et je
voudrais dire en préalable que il ne
faudrait pas croire malgré tout que le
l'immense majorité des femmes souffrent
de violences conjugales évidemment je
sais c'est 100 femmes dont il est
question ici ce sont toutes des drames
individuels mais néanmoins à une époque
de dadt d'archipel nisation si j'ose ce
néologisme comme dirait fourques et use
de morcellement de la société
il serait regrettable de monter les
hommes contre les femmes et
d'essentialiser les hommes en bourreaux
et les femmes aux victimes voilà ce que
je souhaitais malgré tout dire dire en
préalable
maintenant j'avoue que le le le principe
même laisse un petit peu circonspecte
j'ai le sentiment que chacun veut son
grenelle pour marquer son temps et et
que pour le moment on ne s'intéresse pas
aux problèmes de fond qui peuvent
menacer la femme moi je voudrais un
grenelle par exemple de la cohérence je
vous donne un exemple extrêmement simple
et bien on dit il faut apprendre aux
petits cartons je crois que ça fait
partie de ce qui a été évoqué à
respecter les petites filles dès le plus
jeune âge
finalement et bien je vois parmi les
féministes qui sont au premier rang
autour de nos gouvernants des gens qui
n'ont de cesse de dénoncer la galanterie
qui n'était finalement que la traduction
occidentale de notre de ce respect pour
les femmes à prendre au petit garçon
qu'on ne frappe les filles qu'avec même
pas avec des roses et bien c'était
c'était les premiers pas de cela donc
c'est une première incohérence que je
que je trouve là j'en vois encore bien
d'autres gtc en citer une deuxième et je
m'arrêterai là c'est que au premier rang
aussi de ces féministes on voit certains
qui participait au gouvernement hollande
quand la question de la de la loi sur la
récidive sexuelle a été les des
délinquants sexuels a été abordé à c'est
une autre forme de féminicide qui n'est
pas la même que les évidemment les
féminicides conjugaux mais qui néanmoins
est connexe
eh bien on a vu toutes ces féministes
comme christiane taubira faire preuve
d'un grand laxisme
donc je me dis c'était à ce moment là
qu'il fallait faire montre de fermeté et
pas dans des numéros de téléphone où
toutes sortes de mesures qui pour le
moment je reste prudente je veux pas les
juger mais reste me semble-t-il de
l'ordre du gadget jobs
moi ce qui me frappe j'ai écouté donc
pas mal d'intervention ces derniers
jours en prévision de cette ouverture du
grenelle dont contre les violences
conjugales et les chiffres que
j'entendais de la part des associations
spécialisées sur les besoins étaient
très très largement supérieure à ce qui
a été octroyé j'entendais dire qu'il y
avait besoin de centaines de milles
d'euros pour vraiment créer des foyers
créer des structures qui n'existe pas et
là dans l'intervention qu'on a entendu
le premier ni c'était 5 millions d'euros
pour une centaine je crois d'hébergement
donc déjà première question est ce qu'il
n'ya pas un effet sur toutes
communications 1000 nouvelles places
pardon donc est ce qu'il n'ya pas un
effet de communication enfin moi je
trouve très courageux de la part d'un
gouvernement de s'intéresser à ce sujet
de manière publiquement c'est jamais
facile pour un pays de reconnaître qu'on
a un tel problème social comme celui des
violences conjugales
ma question c'est est ce qu'il y a
besoin de mettre en batterie une telle
mobilisation de l'appeler grenelle
contre les violences conjugales de faire
des semaines voir je crois trois mois de
débats et de réflexion là pour le coup
j'ai une vraie interrogation
oui effectivement des grenelles de
n'importe quoi ce ça finit par devenir
fatigante moyennant quoi on a quand même
il faut pas nier qu'on a un problème de
féminicide dans ce pays et qui pourrait
s'aggraver du fait notamment de la
multiplication des crimes de ce qu'on
appelle bêtement les crimes d'honneur
il faut voir qu'en fait on a affaire à
quatre phénomènes assez différent selon
l' oms
vous avez à la fois des féminicides
intimes comme on dit c'est à dire
effectivement ce qu'on voit depuis ce
qu'on a vu ces dernières années une 100
101 cas depuis le début d'année c'est
beaucoup de deux maris ou deux
compagnons qui assassinent leurs femmes
sont presque il les aime aider aime
tellement que quand elle dit qu'elle
veut partir il les tue effectivement
c'est qu'on compte qu'on est considéré
ça longtemps à la lumière de notre
littérature romantique comme une affaire
d'amour est quelque peu paradoxal mais
vous avez également les crimes d'honneur
qui se multiplient on sait très bien
c'est là l'idée que les femmes sont les
propriétés du clan de la famille et que
quand elles dérogent à certains types de
codes d'honneur appartenant à cette même
famille on les tue parce que elle elle
ont transgressé une loi vous avez aussi
et il faut le savoir
c'est pas encore le cas en france mais
c'est le cas dans beaucoup d'autres pays
du sud
vous avez des crimes liés à la dot c'est
très fréquent dans les pays comme l'inde
par exemple que les belles et belle
famille tue la jeune épousée où l'épousé
tout court pour s'emparer de la dot
et puis vous avez le féminicide non
intimes comme dit le ms c'est à dire en
fait une agression sexuelle qui se
termine par un meurtre on peut pas
continuer à fermer les yeux sur les
quatre c4 cas de crimes contre les
femmes parce qu'ils sont de plus en plus
nombreux et parce que nous vivons je
pense à l'échelle mondiale une espèce de
révolution des moeurs qui fait que nous
ne tolérons plus et avec raison
ce type de criminalité alors en france
on n'a pas trop à faire au trot au 2o de
co2 dont coca de numéro 2 et numéro 3
mais quand même on voit qu'en allemagne
on souhaite il ya eu des crimes
d'honneur et c'est donc pire on je pense
que c'est une façon aussi si vous voulez
de faire passer la pilule on pouvait pas
attaquer le crime d'honneur en tant que
tel sans s'attaquer aux autres crimes
comme on dit au féminicide intime et
c'est très bien qu'on s'occupe enfin de
cette affaire-là ce qui brille ce côté
si on veut quand même sous titré de
façon explicite ce qui dit quand il
pleut des trois catégories d'hô chi nous
parle si je comprends pas des crimes
d'honneur à l'accord soit la sicilienne
sont décrits mineures liées à
l'immigration
certaines cultures mais tout ça brille
arcal oui ma fac ils sont donc venus du
maghreb de l'afrique ou du coup le sous
continent indien
je n'avais pas compris que c'était ça
l'objectif du gouvernement
mais pourquoi pas le même nom mais
pourquoi pas après c'est vrai qu'un côté
agaçant c'est grenelle c'est machin tu
au cinéma bon oui c'est ça peut être
agaçant après n'empêche il n'en reste
pas moins que c'est vrai qu'il ya des
femmes battues violente est assassiné
donc si ça peut être utile tant mieux la
justice fait paria en 2017 et 20000
condamnation 20000 condamnation rien que
peut-être dans le premier cas dont vous
parlez qui sont des gars qui battent
leurs femmes donc six ce qu'on fait
permet d'accueillir des femmes
temporairement mais ça peut pas non plus
être la solution c'est qu'il ya pas de
raison qu elle soit la femme qui est qui
et qui serait battue qui doit pas nous
qui devrait partir le mari reste très
tranquillement chez lui donc la vraie
révolution dans ses cales judiciaire
avec la justice doit prendre ses
responsabilités
d'où la nomination de procureurs
spécialisés ça peut peut-être servir
quelque chose ça veut dire aussi que les
juges aux affaires familiales prennent
en compte ces genres de cas parce que
souvent se rend compte que quand il ya
ça le mari tape tout le compagnon de
table sur sa femme etc
mais après sur la question des enfants
et donc le juste fermer à 18 ans va on
va faire la garde alternée
donc chaque fois qu'ils revoient la
famille du retable dessus donc c'est
quand même des choses très compliquées
qu'il faut prendre en compte donc en
dépit du côté un peu avec cette
rhétorique du féminicide et thierry
terra qui peut être agaçante je pense
quand même que si ça permet de régler la
somme de kab'in tant mieux on va pas
faire la fine bouche
le féminicide qui nous dit féminicide on
pourrait dire un homicide ça fait bien
sûr le mi6 cent concernent pas les
hommes c'est bien des êtres humains donc
par ailleurs il faut noter que le mot
homicide n'est même pas dans le code
pénal
il est dans la table des matières du
couple a donc appelé l'on parle de
meurtre tout là toute l'évolution de
notre législation pénale c'est de sortir
de la communautarisation des crimes et
des délits
c'est à dire que on a supplié on a
supprimé luxe or is it qui avait dans
sous l'ancien régime
c'était le droit pour le mari de tuer sa
femme qu'il a su repreneur mauvaise
posture que le premier côté dalle de 10
810 autorise aussi une excuse d'adultère
pour le marié qui
et sous le coup de la colère aurait tué
sa femme donc et tout on a récemment
sorti du code pénal le parricide pour
finalement n'a pu que des meurtres alors
il ya des circonstances aggravantes le
fait de tuer son conjoint est une
circonstance aggravante le fait de tuer
quelqu'un qui a confiance en vous et qui
ont des relations de confiance et une
circonstance aggravante
mais l'idée c'est d'universaliser les
crimes précisément pour les pour eux
pour pour aller à la sepa plus grave de
tuer sa femme qu'un enfant ou quimper
aucune mère va pas commencer à dire il
donc double idée c'est de virer des
meurtres
après il ya des circonstances et donc
l'idée de dire on va créer un délit un
crime qui serait particulier puisque
free mini site c'est de la com bon
puisque je constate c'est qu'il ya en
europe des initiatives qui ont marché je
pense notamment à l'espagne où il ya
cette application extrêmement
apparemment suivi est utilisé sur
téléphone portable qui permet aux femmes
de se signaler aux femmes en danger de
signaler immédiatement la difficulté
qu'elles sont en train de vivre et de
faire intervenir les services de police
j'avoue que je ne comprends pas pourquoi
ce genre d'applications qui existe
ailleurs ne pourrait pas être facilement
importer en france
quelquefois on ferait bien de regarder
en france ce qui se passe à côté parce
que sur des problèmes de société comme
ça avec des pays extrêmement similaire à
la france eh bien il ya peut-être des
solutions qui pourraient être prises
plus rapidement alors parmi les
solutions je rappelle ce soir annonce il
ya également la possibilité de porter
plainte à l'hôpital qui va être
généralisée c'est la question qu'on vous
pose sur twitter est ce que vous pensez
que les premières mesures qui sont
annoncées sont efficaces et pour
l'instant où vous êtes une large
majorité à répondre non babineau
notamment une qui me dit et qu'on salue
ce sont des mesurettes
il faut beaucoup plus d'argent il faut
une prise de conscience collective de la
gravité de la situation c'est votre avis
également non mais je suis frappé de
voir qu'il ya des angles morts y compris
des sujets tabous qui nous gêne ici
autour de cette table et ce qui est ce
qui est normal parce que ce sont des
sujets tabous qui touche toute la
société et qui sont évidemment vous
l'avez évoqué vous l'avez évoqué
également celui de
d'une population qui allochtones qui
arrivent sur notre territoire avec ses
moeurs parce qu'évidemment et son regard
différent sur la femme parce qu'on ne
laisse pas ses moeurs à la frontière et
on les laisse encore moins que on
retrouve une communauté forte qui vous
permet de les conserver et n'ont pas de
dents assimilés d'autres et ça c'est un
sujet qui est vraiment le non dit deux
de ceux dans ce gouvernement c'est à
dire que on pourrait imaginer qu'une
féministe tout à fait pragmatique et en
dehors de tout contexte idéologique est
absolument pas intimider par le
politiquement correct s'interrogerait
légitimement de savoir si et bien une
arrivée massive de gens en provenance de
pays où la condition féminine est
beaucoup plus difficile qu'en france
demandait à une pakistanaise si elle
trouve que la condition féminine est
équivalente au pakistan et en france si
sa plainte sera reçue de la même façon
au pakistan et en france si elle se elle
porte plainte contre son conjoint
et bien si tout cela ne va pas
évidemment avoir une influence est pas
une bonne influence sur notre propre
condition féminine en france
tout cela ce sont des non dits des
tabous et ce quelqu'un qui voudrait
véritablement défendre la femme est bien
ferai en sorte de faire sauter ces
tabous
oui pour rebondir sur ce qui vient
d'être dit et que je trouve important il
faut noter que dans un certain nombre de
pays d'europe occidentale on a vu les
législations faire la jurisprudence
évolué sur ce point on a vu des juges
d'accepter l'idée que certains criminels
ou offensif offensant devrait bénéficier
d'une clémence particulière parce que
dans leur culture leur le regard sur la
femme est différent du nôtre
c'est une dérive qu'il faut absolument
empêcher à tout prix évidemment on peut
pas avoir une justice à deux a plu à
plusieurs étages en fonction de la
culture d'origine des prévenus et il est
bien évident que quelqu'un qui bat sa
femme au qu'il a tu dois être traités de
la même façon qu'ils soient d'origine x
y ou z de religion ou de pas de religion
du tout or je remarque qu'en
grande-bretagne ou en suède par exemple
on a vu certains jugements influencé par
cette affaire certains avocats brandir
le fait que
clients dans son pays a l'habitude de
battre sa femme et qui pourrait bien le
faire aussi en suède c'est évidemment
absolument inacceptable ensuite ça se
passerait comme ans alors il à l'arsenal
juridique qui était extrêmement
vigoureux sur ces questions on n'a pas
le même problème au sens statistique du
terme semble-t-il ou en tout cas le
problème n'est pas arrivé sur le devant
de la scène de la même manière mais ce
que vous dites je sais qu'il ya eu par
exemple clairement des cas avec une lame
minorités qu'aux barres qui est très
très forte en suisse et vous connaissez
aussi les habitudes au sein de la
communauté kosovare d'avec un rôle du
clan très important il ya eu plusieurs
affaires en tout cas ces dernières
années j'ai moins suivi récemment qu'ils
étaient arrivés en justice et les peines
prononcées avait été extrêmement sévère
toute dernière question à tout dernier
point sur ça ce soir jean leonetti
alexis dit aux membres de son parti de
s'emparer de ce sujet sur le féminin la
lutte contre les violences conjugales
d'être d'être plus allants parlez de
quel parti beaucoup utilisé dans des
bourgs et sa fatwa la star il faut déjà
qu'ils seront vains pas trop à brave
héros ce qu'ils peuvent faire dit oui
bien sûr il a raison cette vue de ben
oui ça fait baisser la vie des gens et
puis s'il faut c'est quand même des
souffrances terribles faut enfin les
femmes battues violente il faut pas bon
donc oui faut enfin les jours après on
résoudra pas non plus en claquant des
doigts enfin de plus de volonté il ya
toujours eu des
il faut pas s'en contenter distant
satisfaire ni de dire que c'est qu'il ya
rien à faire mais on va pas supprimer
avec trois mesures législatives les
infanticides les parricides les
féminicides des os et des dents
après faut il faut une politique pénale
il faut de la répression pour empêcher
ce genre de comportement 20% des auteurs
des sur les 100 ha féminicide défense
sur les sens une femme qui ont été tués
depuis le début de l'année sous les
coups de leur mari de compagnons 20% des
auteurs étaient déjà connus des services
de police
donc est ce matin je précise parce que
sony quelqu'un de la fondation des
femmes ce matin sur france info c'est
qu'il y avait également eu un problème
de prise en compta c'est à ce niveau là
on continuera de façon de suivre le
grenelle des ce grenelle sur les
violences conjugales qui doit comme vous
l'aviez dit riesch a duré jusqu'aux
jusqu'à la mi novembre
juste je cite si que nous dit on
pourrait avoir une appli pour les gens
aux hommes aux femmes qui se font
agresser également dans la rue ça c'est
une autre question qui est intéressante
parce que les femmes se sentent en
sécurité je pense encore moins dans la
rue au sein de leur foyer globalement
quand on leur pose en classant dans la
majorité que parler elle permet aux
femmes également de signaler une
éventuelle agression dont elles ont été
victimes
pensez vous que les premières mesures
prises dans le cadre du grenelle contre
les violences conjugales sont efficaces
et bien vous êtes toujours une large
majorité répondre non